[Music]
Mickey's up for grabs so now he's going
to stab this week the 95-year-old
copyright on Disney's early version of
Mickey Mouse AKA Steamboat Willie
expired and now that the Retro rodent
has entered the public domain anyone is
free to use the character's likeness
however they want much to the dismay of
Disney's beleaguered brand managers yeah
apparently they're mad that this could
ruin Disney's
reputation
sorry guys I think you already did that
on your own if you guys had your way
you'd have Mickey encouraging Pinocchio
to lie until his nose is at least 7 Ines
and then call up the Seven Dwarves for a
fairy tale sit and
spin
oh so yeah they word Mickey might be
used in perverse ways true it won't be
long before Mickey sells Pluto to a dog
fighting ring or mocks Donald Duck for
his lisp and not owning pants so there's
already an upcoming onslaught of
Steamboat Willie horror films here's a
clip from one called Mickey Mouse Mickey
Mouse's trap or whatever who
[Music]
cares where the hell did he
go well that sucks they took an iconic
entertainment brand turn it into a
nightmare oo they're also doing a horr
themed video in the video game uh in the
future but when it comes to movies did
they really get the scariest one I think
we
did hey everybody Steamboat Willie here
if you're looking for something fun to
do why not pick up your copy of Brian
Kil me's new book Teddy and Booker T
available now or see Brian on tour
January 21st at the Rialto Square
Theater in joet Illinois and don't
forget to tune in every morning to the
excellent television program Fox and
Friends Joe when you were a kid growing
up in that orphanage you uh you were
deeply attached to Mickey Mouse this was
something that was very important into
your
upbringing uh how do you this must be
kind of a shock to see him treated this
way way he was the only friend I ever
had Back Then Greg I know yeah uh it is
a shock uh to have him see this see to
have him be shown this way uh it's
almost like as bad as Ghostbusters when
those ladies took over yeah and I'm
pretty sure they they couldn't run
upstairs but I'm more
worried I'm more how how are they going
to get you know the other thing too they
were all sixes go ahead how how are they
going to bust ghosts if they're up the
stairs but anyways I'm much more worried
about other people uh taking other
copyrights that have lapsed and and
abusing other old properties like uh
it's not going to be long before Jimmy
Kimmel and Howard Stern do a remake of
Amos and
[Laughter]
Andy yeah cat uh Steamboat Willie sounds
like somebody you dated in
college no I don't really live near any
bodies of
water um
it's because I would have but
um old SEO Will's here get on the why
not sure I'll get on the boat he's got a
chg boat yeah uh I'm you know what's
disturbing to me about this uh is
actually that someone this was clearly
ready for when the you know the
copyright was over like the the lengths
people will go to avoid having to come
up with just a new idea yeah exactly
they're like okay finally now we can use
Mickey Mouse in this different way
everything's a remake it's true it
doesn't matter it's going to be the same
horror movie as all the other which not
in a bad way I love movies like that
that are just like really bad horror
movies but it's going to be the same as
all the other ones I think it's scary as
is Jim I mean I look at Mickey Mouse
he's a frightening little creature do
you think this will help or hurt
Disney's brand you're an expert in in uh
commercial marketing I am Greg yes I
went to college for it for 17 years yes
I'm very I think that it's not going to
help or her Disney what I want is the
the porn version they're usually on top
of this stuff I mean there's been a few
of them Winnie the Pooh is now maybe him
and Minnie have sex and Mickey is a cuck
in the corner like I would love to see
that the porn industry really is late on
on the draw on this one they're usually
very first to to grab something exactly
they're always first on the technology I
found Often by
accident Kennedy you know what I was
thinking it what the cats pointed so
unoriginal they should insert Mickey
into like sitcoms like they did with
cousin Oliver The Brady Bunch absolutely
remember they they brought him in to be
cute because everybody was getting old
up yeah so they threw him in there and
it yeah and then he died it was really
it was a tragic death too he was torn
apart by a homicidal Mouse exactly you
don't hear a lot about it but it it is
part of The Brady Bunch lore and thank
you for bringing that up because that is
part of our nation's history that we
shouldn't be tearing down like statues
of that Susan B Anthony
he didn't say that he did he said she
was a six I'd still go out with her yeah
he'd still go out with her I'm I'm with
Jim like the first thing when I started
reading the story I'm like I want to see
a snuff film like if it's going to be a
horror film then at least like have
Mickey undo those two little buttons woo
this mouth is good for a lot more than
whistling this is turning into one of
those VH1 cut and past specials or how
about the perfect marketing you turn
Epstein Island you call it Steamboat
with
[Laughter]
Island see we solved the world's
problems we solved Disney's problems and
this other billionaire dude that we
brought him together like we bring
America together every night between 10:
and 11: hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else